bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin sur notre chaîne l'audition de
patrick roméo le président directeur
général de shell france sur les enjeux
liés aux aides les zones économiques
exclusives d'outre-mer avec 11 millions
de kilomètres carrés ces zones permet de
bénéficier à la france qui le cinquième
domaine maritime mondial
d'importantes ressources marines et
récemment d'ailleurs ont été découvertes
et exploiter de nouvelles zones
océaniques profonde d'énergie en guyane
et c'est pourquoi patrick roméo défend
un projet de forage pétrolier en guyane
tout de suite donc direction la salle
médicis pour l'audition de patrick roméo
le président directeur général de shell
france très bonne matinée à tous sur
public sénat le président de shell
france mes chers collègues le président
de notre délégation à l'outre-mer notre
collègue de la martinique serge larcher
et malheureusement me dit-on retenu chez
lui pour des raisons de santé
et il m'a demandé de bien vouloir le
supplée en tant que vice-présidente et
ils vous adresse à toutes et tous ses
voeux chaleureux pour 2013 et il compte
nous retrouver bientôt
nous souhaitons la bienvenue à monsieur
patrick roméo président de shell france
et à son équipe
vous étiez monsieur romeo venu le 31 mai
2012 nous présentait le projet
d'exploration pétrolière au large de la
guyane votre audition forte intéressante
avait alors duré plus de deux heures
sans parvenir à épuiser totalement
l'ordre du jour ni étanche et
complètement notre curiosité nous étions
donc convenu de nous revoir lorsque les
opérations d'exploration offshore aurait
progressé ce qui nous permet de
vous revoir aujourd'hui nous n'avions en
particulier abordé que sous un angle
assez théorique les retombées régionales
en termes économiques et d'emploi nous
voulons donc faire un point concret avec
vous sur cette question qui à nos yeux
est capital au-delà du projet
d'exploration pétrolière en cours au
large de la guyane un nouveau sujet est
par ailleurs venu enrichir notre
réflexion sur les enjeux des zones
économiques exclusives ultramarines
c'est le sujet de la réforme du code
minier
nous souhaitons recueillir votre
sentiment sur ce dossier qui viendra
prochainement en discussion au parlement
et en particulier savoir s'il convient
selon vous de ménager une lisibilité
spécifique au sein du futur code minier
pour le régime relatif à l'exploration
et l'exploitation des produits
pétroliers mais dans un premier temps
nous aimerions que vous dresser un bilan
des deux forages déjà effectués si c'est
bien cela du point de vue
environnemental notamment et que vous
traces y est les perspectives des
opérations envisagées pour 2013 donc je
récapitule nous avons une trame de
d'entretien aujourd'hui autour de deux
trois thèmes
tout d'abord le point d'actualité à la
suite du deuxième forage et les
perspectives pour 2013 en 2d les
avancées relatives aux retombées
économiques régionales en termes de
formation et d'emploi et pour le
développement économique de la guyane
et enfin troisième thème la position de
shell france sur le projet de réforme du
code minier
je vous propose donc de procéder 1
nous allons vous vous entendre et
ensuite nous nous procéderont à un
échange avec les sénateurs à l'issue de
la présentation de chacun de ces points
ça permettra d'animer un petit peu le
les changes
si mes collègues corps à part pourra
porter sur le dossier jean etienne
antoinette et sénateurs de la guyane et
joël guerriau sénateur de la loire
atlantique n'ont rien à ajouter à ce
stade je vais vous céder la parole mais
je les interroge d'abord pour savoir
s'ils souhaitent intervenir à ce point
de notre rencontre
non très bien alors je souhaiterais que
nous nous efforcions tout de même de
deux nous cadres et dans un temps
raisonnable
il me semble que en une heure et demie
nous devrions pouvoir abordés
méthodiquement ses 3 ces trois thèmes
alors je vous donne la parole si vous
voulez bien monsieur le président car la
représentation nationale
je vais donc commencer par le point
d'avancement du projet pour rappel c'est
un projet qui a commencé dans sa phase
active
je dirais en 2010 par acquisition de
données sismiques qui ont permis
d'identifier des réservoirs cible à
forer et un premier forage en 2011 a
permis de faire une première découverte
de pétrole dans un d une grappe de bancs
de sable enfouis à 5000 mètres sous
terre qu'on appelle et du cedus un
premier forage a été un succès dans ce
sens qu'il a confirmé l'existence
de l'hydrocarbure donc d'une roche mère
de réservoir de bonne qualité et d'un
système étanche pour que ces
hydrocarbures accumulés au cours des ces
que ce soit sont tous soit toujours ici
suite à ce premier succès nous avons
entamé un deuxième forage sur le même
sur la même grappe de bancs de sable si
je peux dire mais un peu en amont
imaginé un système de rivière
souterraine avec un espèce de delta qui
se forment sous terre et donc nous avons
détecté du pétrole informel ne seront
pas remontés un peu en amont pour
vérifier s'ils avaient également
présence hydrocarbures à cet endroit
donc nous avons foré à 5 km à l'ouest et
en amont de désillus un qu'on appelle
jms dans notre jargon donc lui le forage
a été un grand succès technique en ce
sens qui s'est déroulé conformément au
programme sans aucun accident ou
incident nous avons atteint la
profondeur de 6200 mètres le 3 décembre
2012 et nous avons hélas dû constater
que le raid les réservoirs cibles
étaient vides d'hydrocarbures donc une
déception je dirais en termes
d'exploration une satisfaction en termes
d'opérations mais une déception en
termes d'exploration
oui c'est un investissement très lourd
mais le tout la logique de l'exploration
c'est que nous ferons à chaque fois avec
une probabilité de succès faible et
c'est donc si nous avons raison dans le
concept l'addition de ces forages qui
doit nous permettre de détecter un
gisement commercial donc je dirais
premier succès le premier coup c'était
extraordinaire
nous avions moins de 20% de chances de
succès et nous avons eu un succès donc
c'était vraiment très bien deuxième
forage déception ça veut dire que cet
aveu dire qu'il nous faut chercher
d'autres d'autres poches d'hydrocabures
dans d'autres réserves à et c'est ce que
nous avons commencé maintenant
alors lorsqu'on tamines un forage comme
celui qu'on a terminé en décembre 2012
il s'agit ensuite de reboucher le puits
puisqu'il est évident qu'il faut que le
système soit dans un état tel qu'il ne
puisse pas y avoir de fuites je dirais
de fluides souterrain dans
l'environnement que ce soit de l'eau des
hydrocarbures etc
et donc c'est ce bouchage du puits est à
réaliser conformément au programme
approuvé par là des halles et le navire
a pu se déplacer sur le troisième forage
le 27 décembre 2012
et maintenant nous attaquons un forage
dans une espèce de grappes de réservoir
encore une fois qu'on appelle prio
dantès et voilà donc le le navire arrive
sur zone
il faut d'abord le positionner
dynamiquement je vous rappelle que ont
fort sur une colonne d'eau en
l'occurrence de 1793 met donc le bateau
n'est pas amarré
il est maintenu en position fixe par
positionnement dynamique sur satellite
et sur sonar et donc les moteurs
permettent en permanence de positionner
le bateau seront complique donc ses
activités je dirais deux points fixes
ont commencé et puis et puis nous avons
donc pu commencer le forage nous avons
fort et nous avons installé la tête
depuis nous avons installé le bloc
obturateur de puits ce qui permet
maintenant de forêt en étant totalement
isolé du milieu marin donc nous rentrons
dans la phase très active du forage et
voilà nous espérons donc atteindre les
zones cibles des quelques mois qui
viennent nous sommes à 11,6 km du forage
précédente donc pas très loin mais dans
un système différent ce qu'il faut pour
que nous pensions qu'il y ait un
gisement commercial c'est qu'il y ait
suffisamment de réserves détecté lors
des différents forages pour qu'on pense
qu'il ya un système de production
possible
donc c'est vraiment une question de
quantité et de qualité du pétrole et de
coûts estimés pour extraire ce pétrole
s'il y avait un grand réservoir
facilement accessible c'est bien
meilleur marché que si il y a plusieurs
poches qu'il faut subit simultanément
pompe et voilà donc forage en cours
nous avions aussi en 2012 réalisé deux
campagnes sismiques et donc nous en
sommes au stade où nous interprétons les
données de ces sismique qui sont de
grandes échographie est le résultat de
ces sismique nous permettra de compléter
notre connaissance du sous sol et
d'estimer quelles sont les meilleures
forage à faire dans l'avenir puisque
l'idée bien sûr c'est c'est de trouver
quelque chose d'exploitable le plus
rapidement possible voilà donc je dirais
que mi 2013 nous aurons une meilleure
connaissance du sous-sol pas réparé
sismique
et nous aurons eu aussi les données
accumulées dans les forages qui nous
permettront de faire un point un peu sur
le sur le potentiel de la zone alors une
déception après un succès ça veut pas
dire que le projet rue en cause ça veut
simplement dire que l'explorateur de
faire son travail qui est de forêt mais
bien sûr un succès dans le puits numéro
deux aura été un très grand
encouragement pour les équipes et pour
la collectivité
je peux peut-être faire un petit point
sur la sismique avant de prendre les
questions sur l'avancement des travaux
je pense qu'il ya encore une lettre
visuel sur la cela sismique
voilà donc c'est la voilà les deux zones
brune à 150km lâchant les deux zones est
et ouest sur lesquels il y à eut acquis
this ion de données l'an dernier la zone
du milieu où il ya le combat c'est la
zone que nous avons déjà et dans le
cadre de dole l'autorisation de mener
ses campagnes
nous avons convenu avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes de faire des campagnes
de pêche
donc si campagne de pêche sur plusieurs
années afin d'avoir une connaissance de
la ressource
pendant la saison des pluies pendant la
saison sèche et sur un programme
répétitif de façon à ce qu'on puisse
extraire des données pertinentes
donc ces campagnes de pêche ont eu lieu
avec la participation d'armement
guyanais donc les pêcheurs lyonnais ont
participé du 2 au 11 décembre
voilà donc nous sommes parfaitement en
phase avec des prescriptions qui nous
ont été
demande donc voilà pour la partie
activité est ce que vous serez ravis de
répondre à vos questions bien sûr
l'entretien mes chers collègues c'est
vous qui avez la parole sur ce premier
point sur les travaux en cours et les
perspectives de l'année 2013
je me tourne vers nos rapporteur est ce
que vous souhaitez enfin sur ce premier
point moi j'aimerais bien quand même que
vous estimez que vous nous donner des
éléments de coût ce qu'est ce que ça
représente
ces forages en termes de 2,9
d'investissement de votre part pour
arriver à un résultat qui puisse être
probants il dure et du forage
il ya à peu près 450 personnes qui
travaillent sur ce projet et il ya donc
des équipements importants qui sont
mobilisés je rappelle que les deux des
statistiques du commerce extérieur ont
fait état d'une location longue durée de
presque 1 milliard d'euros pour pour les
quelques années qui viennent donc ça
donne un peu un ordre de grandeur et le
chiffre communément communiqué c'est que
ces campagnes coût de plus d'un million
de dollars par jour
donc si vous faites un forage de 150
jours bas vous est ce à un coût
supérieur à 150 millions de dollars
alors ce sont des coûts tels que les
gens pensent que si l'on force et que
l'on sait pas ce qu'il est difficile
d'imaginer qu'on puisse dépenser autant
d'argent sans certitude au les guyanais
que je rencontre me disent toujours me
sûr mais vous savez vous gérer
l'information parce que cela vous
arrange
mais en fait vous savez non je réitère
ici très pudiquement et très
solennellement que nos techniques
permettent d'identifier des réservoirs
cible mais ils sont à une profondeur
tels que nous ne devons forêt pour
savoir il est tout à fait ce qui s'est
passé d'ailleurs dans le forage du
numéro deux il ya eu hydrocarbures mais
les hydrocarbures
dans la nature ont tendance à remonter
naturellement dans les océans
migros fil des millions d'années donc
l'état normal de ces systèmes c'est que
il y a eu accumulation puis fuite
jusqu'à la mer alors on vérifie s'il n'y
a pas des traces d'hydrocarbures au fond
de la mer c'est une indice de d'étancher
il n'y en avait pas mais il n'empêche
que le système n'a pas été dangereux il
ya énormément de raison qui peut faire
qu'un système ne soit pas étanche on
parle des échelles de temps 200 millions
d'années ici donc donc nous devons aller
voir mais je dirais c'est le il faut
mesurer les revenus bien sûr au regard
de ses dépenses qui sont faites pour
chercher ça coûte très cher de chercher
la probabilité de succès fait mais
lorsqu'on trouve il faut être capable de
rémunérer tous ces coups qui auraient
été qui ont été générées notamment dans
les forages qui ont été des échecs tout
là toute l'économie de l'exploration
tourne autour de ça donc c'est cher mais
c'est un investissement consenti et
d'ailleurs qui est exclusivement assuré
par le privé est en fait c'est une façon
pour le priver de d'identifier de
mesurer le patrimoine de l'état puisque
je rappelle que les ressources
appartiennent à l'état nous nous sommes
que les révélateurs de cette ressource
et en contrepartie je l'espère l'état
nous donne oreilles de concession
d'exploitation pour que nous extrayons
cette ressource et la valeur générée par
cette extraction est ensuite réparti
entre la collectivité et l'investisseur
comme rémunération de son train merci
mais la présidente vous avez rappelé
dans vos propos introductif que de
grandes options sont à prendre en
considération pour qu'un éventuel projet
industriel se double d'un projet
économique
donc je voudrais poser des questions à
la fois sur les effets l'activité et les
effets économiques locaux
alors première question ça passe sur la
transparence
monsieur le président suit alors vous
avez dit que la deuxième phase
d'exploration a été un échec
dès lors soyons précis sur la première
phase pouvez vous nous dire aujourd'hui
quelle est la quantité d'hydrocarbures
quantifier dans la première phase
d'exploration
première question deuxième question
ce fut un débat lors de nos premières
discussions
donc lors de l'audition du mois de mer
en particulier par ma collègue le dévers
sur eux
un dispositif nouveau que vous avez
utilisé
vous avez des nommés dans que une
technique de biocarburants alors est-ce
qu'on peut tirer déjà les enseignements
de cette technologie de nouvelles en
termes du rouget est ce que donc vous
venez des précisions par rapport à la
réglementation en cours vous savez que
la réglementation et puis on a fait un
exposé cet après midi sur le analyse
comparative haut niveau donc mondial
donc en matière de rejet qui est de
l'ordre de 5% est ce que c'était au delà
ce qu'il y a eu pendant la deuxième
phase vous avez rappelé que vous n'ayez
pas donc d'hydrocarbures mois dans la
première phase est ce qu'il y à eut donc
rejet de du pétrole par rapport à ces
d'exploitation est maintenant dans le
domaine cette fois ci plus économique et
en matière d'emploi vous avez précisé
qu'il y a eu le deuxième
même s'il a précisé qu'on voulait le
deuxième alors on va sur cette phase
alors quantité alors quantité nous avons
dit à l'issue du premier forage que nous
estimions qu'il y avait des réserves de
300 millions de barils aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas d'éléments qui permettent de
donner une information complémentaire
puisque nous ne disposons pas de données
supplémentaires suite au deuxième marche
ce que je peux dire c'est qu'il faut
plus que ça a priori pour que pour qu'un
développement dans ce contexte soit
envisageable donc il faut trouver encore
et j'espère que donc le forage en cours
permettra de compléter cette image là ça
veut dire combien beaucoup pour
l'équilibré que nous mais la rentabilité
économique pour vous ce raid est combien
alors c'est pas encore possible de le
dire ce que gilles rappelle qu'il ya
trois paramètres à prendre en compte
quantité et qualité du pétrole mais
aussi le coût d'extraction
parce que s'ils se trouvaient que nous
et nous trouvions deux réservoirs dont
la somme est correct mais qu'ils soient
éloignés de 40 km veillez qu'il est plus
difficile et cela coûte plus cher que
d'extraire le pétrole d'un seul
réservoir donc il ya une dimension de
coûts de développement qui est vraiment
lié à la géologie donc deuxième
paramètre à ce stade on ne le connaît
pas et puis bien sûr il ya tout l'aspect
fiscal
il est évident que tout ceci étant dit à
la fin il faut que les conditions
fiscales permettent d'assurer un
développement rentable pour
l'investisseur donc ça fait trois
paramètres
aujourd'hui nous disposons de certitudes
sur aucun des trois sauf seule certitude
c'est qu'il ya du pétrole
et ça c'est une très grande nouvelle
puisque la chimie du pétrole
l'existence d'une roche mère c'est un
événement géologique ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui se rencontrent souvent
donc on sait que la guyane à ce
potentiel mais il faut une roche mère il
faudrait savoir de bonne qualité c'est à
dire que lorsqu'il ya du pétrole dedans
il veut bien s'extraire sans trop de
coups et puis il faut bien et
suffisamment donc idée système étanche
et ça et ça nécessite cet essor donc on
est vraiment au début de cette campagne
d'exploration de prospection
il y a encore donc trois forages prévus
cette année donc un encours +2 j'espère
qu'ils généreront suffisamment de
données pour répondre à votre question
mais c'est tout c'est toute la question
que c'est ça y at il d un développement
commercial
donc ça c'est sur l'aspect quantité et
les potentiels de développement
commercial le deuxième point c'est sur
l'utilisation de fuite synthétique de
forage le premier puits gm es 1 a été
fait avec de l'eau or l'essentiel des
couches que l'on traverse sont des
argiles et certains sauront que lorsqu
on mouille delargy l'argile sèche avec
de l'eau ça devient ça gonfle et ça
devient extrêmement collants et visqueux
et ça pose énormément de problèmes dans
le premier puisque nous avons failli
abandonner trois fois parce que on n'y
arrivait pas l'eau n'était pas le tihad
apte et c'était comme percer un mur en
béton avec une mèche à bois mais nous
n'avions pas le choix c'était la
prescription préfectorale muni de cette
expérience ou autre j'ai dit aux gens
écouter tout le monde cherche la
sécurité alors donnez nous des outils
pour forer correctement c'était devenu
pour moi une cause ou condition de
continuer le projet parce que un
professionnel ne peut pas travailler
sont des bons outils
donc nous avons utilisé ces fuites
synthétique de forage ce sont des fuites
qui sont conçus 1 pour être non toxique
et nous disposons de trente années
d'études d'écotechnologies qui démontre
que c'est pas toxique il est hors de
question de rendre l'environnement
toxiques et en plus ils savent ils sont
performants lors ce confort d argile
et le deuxième forage a été absolument
remarquable en termes de qualité de
forage nous avons dû interrompre le
forage numéro 2 pendant plusieurs
semaines pour des raisons de courant et
nous avions estimé que les courants
nécessitait qu'on interrompe les travaux
nous avons pu reprendre le forage
quelques semaines après avec un puits
absolument intact parce que ces fuites
ont aussi une qualité de préservation du
forage extrêmement importante avec de
l'eau nous aurions dû recommencer
or recommencer c'est passé du temps sur
zone et l'impact environnemental est
évidemment supérieur donc ce bilan a été
fait puisqu'il faisait partie des
conditions de l'ouverture de travaux
nous doivent nous devions faire un bilan
faire faire un bilan par un tiers
ce bilan a été fait j'ai vu les
conclusions en diagonale elles sont très
favorables aux choix qui a été fait sur
toutes ses dimensions et cette tierce
expertise ena et maintenant analysées
par un tiers pour le compte des services
de l'état de façon à ce que le contenu
soit validée par une partie indépendant
mais le contenu dont je peux me souvenir
est extrêmement favorable à ce choix et
je pense qu'il est fondamental de
continuer dans cette voie est bien
entendu que les fluides on ne les
rejette pas en mer il n'y a eu aucun
rejet de pétrole en mer
lorsque l'on d'abord les fluides ne sont
utilisés que lorsqu'on est en boucle
fermée donc ce sont des fuites qui coûte
une fortune
l'os est bon marché les fuites sont très
chers donc il n'y a aucun intérêt à
aller à les jeter
même s'ils sont pas toxiques donc on les
recycle met donc les rejets dont on
parle ce sont des résidus de fuites sur
les remblais
donc s'il ya aucun geste de m à la mer
des fluides ce sont les déchets propres
qui sont que l'on rejette en mer avec
une traces résiduelles de fuite
nous n'avions pas le droit de rejeter
avec +2 5% et nous avons atteint des
taux de de réduire de présence de ces
fuites de l'ordre de 1 6%
donc parce que nous avons encore une
fois essayé de minimiser ces rejets donc
tout ce bilan sera sera disponible sur
dvd que l'expert de la dea alors on aura
validé le contenu je pense avoir répondu
à vos questions sur l'aspect technique
sénatrice archimbaud toujours sur ce
premier point et est très brièvement
puis vous avez déjà donné un certain
nombre d'éléments
je voulais que vous nous rappelez vous
l'avez peut-être dit la dernière fois à
quelle profondeur son ont été faits les
forages de la première phase
premièrement deuxièmement vous avez
évoqué un tiers donc est ce qu'on peut
savoir qui est le tiers enfin vous avez
dit que ce serait public un tiers qui va
faire le bilan donc voilà c'est reparti
et j'ai le souvenir en effet et mon
collègue évoqué à l'instant que lors de
la dernière audition vous aviez évoqué
ce fameux 5 % et était enfin pouvaient
être toxiques quoi donc là vous nous
indiquez que non ça n'est vous avez
changé c'est ne sont plus toxiques c'est
ça enfin c'est ce que je sais le
souvenir que j'ai pas mes documents
voilà ces trois questions très brève
avant qu'on passe à la suite sur la
toxicité je rappelle que
est non toxique et ce n'est pas moi qui
le dis il est classé par la législation
riche européenne comme un produit non
toxique
donc il est testé non il est conçu et
testé non toxique
sauf que c'est un fluide synthétique
donc on l'a fabriqué ce n'est pas de
l'eau et faut savoir que l'eau que l'on
utilise comme puis devant je n'ai pas de
l'eau pure on rajoute deux dans des
choses qui permettent de l'utiliser
comme puits de forage donc je ne sais
pas qui est plus plus synthétique une
fille née en fin de compte entre de
l'eau dans laquelle on met des additifs
ou un foot synthétique conçue pour être
non toxiques dans lequel on met moins
d'additifs de ce fait le 5 % c'était une
norme imposée par l'état
il faut savoir que le les normes
internationales sont très au delà mais
tout simplement parce qu'il faut mettre
une limite
il est légitime de toute façon il faut
qu'on minimise des rejets même si les
filles sont pas toxiques et aucun
intérêt à les rejeter volontairement
donc il faut qu'ils normes qui
permettent de s'assurer que l'opérateur
est efficace travail
professionnellement et donc qu'il ait
quelques contraintes 5% c'était la
prescription on a fait mieux
on a fait mieux parce que nous disposons
d'un navire extraordinaire donc si ce
navire était remplacé par un autre
nous ne sommes pas sûrs de faire aussi
bien mais nous nous sommes engagés à
faire 5%
voilà donc pour nous les fluides ce
n'est pas face c'est le meilleur choix
en termes d'impact puisque plus vous
ferez vite moi vous êtes présent moi
vous rejetez une fine et moi - vous
perturber l'environnement
après sur donc nous avions forêt aussi à
6000 mètres sur le premier un petit peu
moins profond mais nous sommes restés
plus longtemps puisque nous avons trouvé
donc nous avons fait des analyses
complètes claires donc un forage
une fois que vous êtes sur une zone
intéressante ou prend du temps pour
extraire des échantillons de pétrole
nous avons remonté des gouttes d du
pétrole à la surface pour l'analyser
nous avons remonté des échantillons de
roches
quand c'est un échec on n'a pas besoin
de faire tout ça donc on on reste un peu
moins de temps ailleurs et on peut si
elle ferait un peu plus loin pour voir
s'il ya quelque chose de sous qu'on
n'aurait pas pas détecté ou en tout cas
pour construire de la connaissance
donc parce qu'il s'agit peut-être de
tirer des enseignements est ce que dès
lors le préfet pourrait prendre des
arrêtés limitant le rejet à 3% ce qui
vous donnerait une marge pour ce que
vous dites que le rejet de 5%
c'est ce qu'on a réussi à faire sur ce
j'ai bien compris est-ce que dorénavant
on peut dire que la doctrine
réglementaire serait de 3%
le première question avec des deuxièmes
qui sont toujours sur cette première
phrase que répondez-vous aux
interrogations très forte des marins
pêcheurs qui dénonce le manque d'études
dans cette phase de formation sur la
ressource halieutique d'accord donc pas
l'aspect réglementaire
d'abord je répète il y fit ne sont pas
toxiques
donc on pourrait rejeter 100% de la
communauté scientifique s'accorde pour
dire que ce n'est pas tant que ça ne
coûte ce serait idiot ça ne coûtera une
fortune
donc la norme elle n'est là que pour
s'assurer que les opérations soient
soient menées de façon ponctuelle c'est
à dire qu'on ne rejette pas n'importe
quoi en mer donc qu'il y ait sur le
bateau des équipements qui permettent
de s'assurer que tout fonctionne en
boucle fermée que l'on nettoie et c'est
prêt on a fait un an et demi pour cent
ou encore une fois parce que c'est une
le bateau le permet le prochain bateau
ne permettra peut-être pas 5%
nous avons estimé qu'avec les les
équipements par exemple lowe's cos de la
plateforme de forage que nous avions
utilisé sur le premier puits n'aurait
pas permis d'atteindre 3%
donc après lorsque lorsqu'on décide que
le meilleur choix des fluides
c'est le meilleur choix il faut pas
ensuite l'interdire par une par une
augmentation trop contraignant toutefois
fait faut être cohérent
déjà la france a fait ce que personne
d'autre n'a fait puisqu'on a mis cinq
pour cent soixante et un chiffre rond et
aucune rue aucune raison 4,9 plutôt que
5,1 sauf que 5 ça sonne bien
sachant que la norme elle est très
supérieur dans tous les pays qui les
utilisent donc encore une fois la france
a été proactif soit j'ai essayé de
défendre l'idée que c'était peut-être un
peu excessif mais est bon mais bon je
crois que tout ceci est une affaire de
raison il faut être raisonnable dans
toutes les dimensions du terrain à 1
ressources halieutiques
non parce qu'il ya quand même un aspect
scientifique derrière qui est de très
important il il est exact que la
connaissance du milieu marin guyane
n'est pas très développée surtout en
tout cas 150 km au large
il ya une connaissance mais si nous
devions développer une plateforme de
production c'est-à-dire une présence
permanente au large d'une usine
d'extraction
je pense qu'il faudrait il faudra
accumuler de la connaissance pour que
les choix de conception de 7
c'est une idée flottante répondre au
mieux à la réduction de l'impact
environnemental
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas présents
au delà présence que l'on en mer c'est
équivalent à la présence d'un oeil
je trouve que le navire reste fixe
pendant quelques quelques mois mais
techniquement c'est un bateau et dans
l'histoire sur les dix années de vie en
guyane il y aura eu quelques mois où un
bateau a été immobilisé donc l'impact il
est il et spots il n'ya pas longtemps
pas content si je fais un développement
de changer pendant trente ans des
installations large
là on a besoin tous d'une connaissance
pour pour que nous puissions faire les
choix de conception qui seraient les
plus pertinents pour à la fois produire
façon sûre économique et aussi de façon
à réduire l'impact 7 7
ce travail est prise en compte dans un
groupe de travail recherche piloté par
les scientifiques de guyane donc ils
viennent de définir le programme de
construction d'une connaissance long
terme là on parle vraiment de de
l'hypothèse où un développement
commercial se fait donc idée on dispose
de plusieurs années pour faire ses
études
vincent ce que la donnée soit disponible
dans au moment où il faudrait concevoir
un système donc cette donnée papaya il
ya des choses qui existent bien sûr mais
c'est pas encore on peut pas dire qu'il
ya un état zéro de la ressource qui se
fait très très brièvement c'était ma
troisième question le le nom du tiers
qui a travaillé pour vous enfin pour
faire le bilan
si j'ai bien compris enfin sur le même
jeu vous pourrez vous le communiqué
c'est une société qui a été désigné par
l'état
c'est ça nous avons proposé un certain
nombre de candidats allaient alors
sélectionné à l'état français qui a
choisi fait ça voilà si on peut avoir le
nom ça c'est simplement qu'il ne vient à
l'esprit spontanément mais
lorsqu'on en a eu plusieurs donc je sais
plus laquelle est le bon mais par contre
ces données puisque ce sont des données
qu'on communique c'est juste un bilan un
évaluation de la pertinence du choix
il est remis à l'état donc j'imagine
qu'il est accessible au même titre qu'un
certain nombre de il ya peut-être pas à
ma connaissance il doit pouvoir être
consultés mais j'ai quelqu'un pourrait
vérifier pour moi
enfin en tout cas ça fait partie des
obligations que l'on la de remettre ce
rapport et ce rapport aussi prescrit ce
qu'on peut faire pour réduire le taux de
rejet aussi ça la fois un rapport qui
mesure la pertinence mais qui donne
aussi des idées sur la suite annoncé
qu'il y aurait deux autres forages sur
la campagne de 2013
est-ce que vous avez déjà une
prospective sur sur la suite alors
lorsqu'on a on a fait les demandes
d'ouverture de travaux la législation
impose de dire où on fore donc nous
avons défini cinq points de forage qui
nous paraissaient être pertinent compte
tenu de l'information qu'on avait le
troisième forage elle a déjà fait
légèrement quelques kilomètres à
quelques kilomètres de l'endroit
initialement prévu puisque compte tenu
de la connaissance qu'on a acquise dans
le deuxième forage
nous avons connu avec l'état qu on
pouvait se déplacer de vraiment quelques
kilomètres dont on a considéré que les
conditions les données étaient était
suffisamment proche pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de problème pour le faire c'est par
contre nous pourrions être amenés pour
la suite nous apprenons quelque chose de
nouveau de penser que puisque puisqu'il
faut puisque nous avons un programme de
forage autant dépenser l'argent de façon
père tient donc on pourrait être amené
peut-être à a posé la question beau est
ce que finalement vous n'aurez pas mieux
forêt
danses telles zones plutôt que cette
zone que nous avions initialement
annoncés et puis il faudrait voir qu'est
ce que nous devons faire pour obtenir
les autorisations problème j'imagine un
échantillonnage du milieu a pas une
acquisition de connaissances qui permet
de penser que c'est que c'est un choix
acceptable
votre intervention l'instant me pousse à
une question qu'est-ce que vous permet
d'optimiser ou quels sont les éléments
qui peuvent vous être apportées pour
optimiser vous vos chances de réussite
en terme de connaissance de la ressource
pétrolière est derrière est ce qu'il ya
des niveaux que vous êtes à 10 et de
franchir en termes de profondeur jusqu'à
coup jusqu'à quelle profondeur vous
lancez vous dans cette aventure
d'accord il s'agit là je dirais de
d'analystes de type échographie 1 et une
campagne sismique c'est une pipe line
technique d'échographie et s'interprète
comme les échographies médical sauf
qu'on n'est jamais allé nous étions
jamais allé à cette profondeur donc
énormément de données dans les modèles
sont estimés à partir d'échantillons
qu'on prélève à terre dont on se dit que
ce qui est présent solar ifth par
extrapolation est présent à 400 m sous
l'eau plus loin un exter donc on essaye
de calais bruno bonnell et chaque fois
confort on remonte les rushs que l'on
rencontre et ont comparé à ce qu'on
avait estimé donc si on pensait qu'il y
avait de l'argile on regarde si on a vu
large il si oui très bien sinon on
modifie légèrement
donc chaque fois que l'on fort les
modèles deviennent de plus en plus
précis donc si tôt au deuxième forage on
a pu légèrement calibré d'infos bien
faut bien comprendre que ce raffinement
est essentiel parce qu'on fort quand
même à 6000 mètres peut qu'imaginer que
je suis ici et que je
et que je fort je sais pas au grand
palais j'ai pas quelle est la distance
je sais à peu près où est le grand
palais maintenant je peux me tromper
d'un mètre être inconnu du grand palais
ou dedans oui
donc il ya quand même un élément
itératif dans la dans la connaissance
qu'on développe donc chaque fois confort
alors j'ai dit qu'on avait eu un succès
technique c'est aussi parce qu'on a bien
trouvé le sable on pensait qu'il était
ce qui quand même toujours pour moi
remarquable un but lui l'endroit où on
se place pour le savoir
après le show qu'on utilise tous les
raffinements au mieux au mieux pour à la
fois pour la collectivité et pour nous
puisque il faut il faut utiliser la
ressource de long à un permis de forer
les 450 personnes et cette expertise
pour maximiser nos chances de succès
alors après où est-ce qu'on s'arrête
encore une fois il faut c'est comme
lorsque vous faites un forage pour l'eau
chez vous vous avez un forfait pour
forer à 50 m à beaucoup de temps et
chaque mètre supplémentaire vous coûte
une fortune ya un moment où vous essayez
51 52 53 puis un moment où vous dites
bon j'arrête
il n'y a pas de contraintes techniques
les équipements permettent d'aller à 10
km à forer dans une autour de plus
grande
après c'est une question de
de de connaissances que l'on acquiert de
rapport coût bénéfices en quelques
auditions
juste une petite pétition je crois
savoir qu'un de vos partenaires total
déposer des permis pour intervenir seul
ce qui est une mésentente entre vous
qu'est ce qui pousse total intervenir
seul dans la zone alors il faut voir
total n'est pas le seul à avoir déposé
des demandes de permis et bats la raison
pour laquelle ils déposent leur permis
indépendamment des nôtres c'est parce
qu'on s'est pas mis d'accord sur encore
une fois on créé des alliances intel
peut vouloir 80% 50 % 30 % vous peut
vouloir être opérateur pour opérateurs
et après c'est une situation un accord
voilà donc cissé mais ce qui est
intéressant dans la démarche est de voir
que des gens soient intéressés par des
permis donc intéressé par explorer en
plus de ce que l'on fait nous mêmes
alors s'il obtenait ce permis exclusifs
de recherche mais il serait exclusif à
eux-mêmes et donc nous serions pas si
dit ceci dit il ya d'autres demandeurs
donc et après c'est à l'état de voir qui
est le mieux disant si j'ose dire et de
toute façon la loi prévoit une mise en
concurrence
donc il ya tout un processus qui fait qu
algérie je ne sais pas d'abord si l'état
autoriserait et de ce qu'ils
attribueraient le permis est ce que fait
souvent les tasses et qui demande aux
gens qui demandent de se mettre d'accord
historiquement j'entends pardon de
vous presser un petit peu parce que je
vois leur qui tourne je souhaite que
nous passions au deuxième thème qui est
évidemment celui qui nous préoccupe le
plus encore que tout ce que vous nous
dites sur les conditions techniques de
l'exploration est tout à fait
passionnant mais j'aimerais que vous
abordiez maintenant les les retombées
économiques
en termes de formation d'emploi quel
quelles évolutions sur l'économie de la
guyane depuis que ceux-ci étaient
entrepris vous aviez évoqué beaucoup ce
thème lors de premières exposées mais
évidemment vous vous en étiez encore au
un peu aux prémices de l'opération donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer là
dessus oui avec plaisir donc déjà je
rappelle les vraies retombées
économiques
c'est lorsqu'il ya un développement
commercial puisque à la fois pour le
coup une usine au large avec des emplois
une activité conséquente et ya là je
dirais la rente pétrolière qui sont les
vrais les vrais outils de génération de
richesse pour la collectivité et le
l'exploitant aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une phase de prospection donc par
définition des opérations ponctuelles
comme répétitives mec mais nous si
vraiment nous sommes très déçus par ce
qui se passe on peut les il ya une
possibilité que finalement tout s'arrête
donc je veux simplement dire par là
qu'il ya un côté ponctuelles donc je
dirais que les impacts aujourd'hui son
lit à la prospection et sont donc
opportuniste dire qu'on fait tout ce
qu'on peut pour générer un maximum
d'activités aujourd'hui en guyane et le
plus vite possible dans le cadre d'un
système de prospection ça veut dire que
il faut qu on utilise au mieux les
entreprises bns pour supporter les
activités de prospection et nous avons
150 entreprises de guyenne répertoriées
aujourd'hui qui son fournisseur de
services de bien à chelles et ses
partenaires un des exemples par exemple
c'est l'affrètement des navires des
pêcheurs pour faire les campagnes de
pêche
en parallèle avec les campagnes
sismiques c'est de l'avitaillement du
navire en produits frais c'est celle et
ce sont les navettes air france
utilisation d'hélicoptères et ses terres
externe a donc à fin septembre 2012 nous
avions dépensé donc de juin à septembre
nous avions dépensé 2 millions d'euros
sur ses dépenses courantes de
prospection si je peux les appeler comme
ça après il faut savoir que ce qui est
très important pour pour que ces ses
retombées opportunistic ça produit c'est
qu'on utilise le port de cayenne lorsque
nous sommes arrivés en guyane
historiquement nous n'avons pas eu accès
au port puisque la colle et les
exploitants du port estimé qu'il n'avait
pas la capacité à satisfaire nos besoins
donc nous nous sommes orientés sur une
logistique avec comme base principale
trinidad trinidad et nous avons cherché
à utiliser cayenne comme une base
secondaire
mais lorsqu'on regarde l'évolution
d'utilisation du port elle est en
augmentation constante puisque toutes
les parties apprennent à utiliser le
port au mieux nous on sait ce qu'on peut
y trouver et le port sait comment gérer
dans nos demandes donc et le port est
maintenant rentré dans le giron d'un
grand port maritime et et je pense que
nous aurons encore plus de moyens pour
renforcer cette activité
oui le port de cayenne donc la réforme a
été mise en oeuvre
j'en ai donc il ya maintenant un grand
port maritime de guyane je pense qu'ils
s'appellent et avec des équipes qui sont
maintenant très bien équipée pour que
l'on développe de l'activité ça va être
un effet d'accélération très important
après il ya des choses techniques comme
la création d'un entrepôt sous douane
donc il faut le temps de créer pour
qu'il y ait de plus en plus
d'équipements qui transitent par cayenne
nous allons chercher à utiliser des
lignes maritimes régulières pour générer
parce que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
d'une flotte dédiée des puits nous
essayons aussi de partager des moyens
entre entre cayenne et qu on est donc
toute une toute toute une série de
projets en cours pour augmenter
l'activité sur sur la guyane
et puis il ya bien sûr un certain nombre
d'emplois que c'est vrai qu'ils ont été
créées qui sont sur la led visuel
suivante
alors ça c'est alors ça c'est un peu la
décomposition des des 2 millions d'euros
à fin septembre je rappelle ce pas très
lisible j'en suis désolé mais mais il y
a des frais de support de transport des
équipements informatiques de
l'hôtellerie des loyers de la
maintenance du salaire transport de
personnes d c'est que c'est un carburant
entretien propros graphie et un ensemble
de
contribution à des organisations
professionnelles liées à l'activité
alors ce qui est par contre un élément
fondamental dans la logistique c'est
l'aéroport félix éboué qui est la base
aéroportuaire principal les équipages
des navires transitent par l'aéroport de
kayes viennent d'europe souvent donc les
vols air france sont connaissent une
fréquentation très importante pour les
rotations de personnel il ya trois
hélicoptères qui assure les rotations
depuis l'aéroport jusqu'au sénat qui a
150 km ça fait plus de cent passagers
transportés par semaine trois vols par
jour six jours sur sept le dimanche est
consacré à la maintenance des
hélicoptères nous souhaitons faire plus
ça nécessite la construction de hangars
donc un ensemble d'investissements
d'infrastructures qui sont nécessaires
pour accompagner la montée en puissance
qui en plus sont des investissements je
dirais sans regret si nous arrêtions un
jour les les infrastructures carey
aurait toujours un intérêt pour la
collectivité alors chez nous nous avons
créé va directement dans notre équipe
nous avons créé 19 emplois
et nous venons juste de recruter cinq
stagiaires alors c'est agir ce qui est
intéressant ce qui doit être employé à
cayenne
mais aussi en europe à la haye aux pays
bas et à paris de façon à ce qu'ils
l'ensemble de ces stagiaires en guyane
sont donc viendront pour ce pour ceux
qui sont en reviendra en europe pour
pour assurer leur stage ce qui permettra
à ces cinq personnes d'avoir une
connaissance maximum de l'ensemble de
l'activité des piges viendrait après sur
l'aspect recrutement non pas de
stagiaires mais de personnel en cdi
il ya eu beaucoup de communication et
d'information auprès des jeunes nous
avons collecté 170 c b à ce jour que
nous sommes en train d'analyser pour
pour un recrutement d'une dizaine de
personnes et nous avons mis en oeuvre un
programme d'apprentissage de l'anglais
puisque l'activité pétrolière nécessite
une bonne connaissance de l'anglais et
la collectivité et nous mêmes avons
estimé qu'il y avait besoin de renfort
ce niveau d'anglais pour que les gens
est un accès plus facile à nos métiers
ceci est en cours et puis nous
travaillons avec des partenaires
fp et autres pour amener des gens en
guyane qui puisse faire mettre en oeuvre
des programmes éducatifs auprès de la
jeunesse dans les écoles c'est pour
sensibiliser les jeunes aux métiers du
pétrole
et puis il ya en plus donc maintenant il
ya nous sommes en train de recruter un
chargé de mission pour la commission de
suivi
je rappelle que nous sommes engagés à
mettre des moyens pour la commission de
suivi pour qu'elles puissent assurer sa
mission donc notamment par le biais d'un
recrutement de chargés de mission il y à
shell va recruter une dizaine de
personnes en 2013 bah ce sont des
recrutements pérennes sont pas des
stagiaires
j'avais expliqué ce lieu il ya quelques
temps que il nous faut construire une
foule de guyane est je dirais qu'ils
puissent couvrir l'ensemble des palais
métiers du pétrole mais très qualifiés à
moins qualifiés et donc nous commençons
à recruter une dizaine alors ce sont des
gens dans une dizaine pourquoi c'est
parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
certitudes sur ce qui se passera par la
suite anglais mais on sait que 10
personnes on peut les faire fonctionner
dans opel comme des recrues normal le
deal c'est qu'on les recrute il
travaille dans groupe shell et puis si
un projet guyane viendront bien sûr
mettre leurs talents aux contributions
de guyenne et puis ce programme va
s'amplifier se moduler en fonction des
résultats et cette démarche est aussi
adopté par nos partenaires
donc nous allons avoir un ensemble de
deux recrues mail à long terme ce qui
est intéressant c'est que les métiers du
pétrole subissent une crise un peu de
croissance il n'y a pas assez de gens
dans le monde donc des guyanais qui sont
volontaires pour quitter la guyane et
travailler dans le monde peuvent trouver
des emplois au sein de cette filière
pétrole d'où l'intérêt de ford et même
s'il n'ya pas un jour de prochain en
guyane
donc nous sommes en train d'évaluer tous
ses besoins de recrutement de l'ensemble
des partenaires
et puis nous sommes aussi en train de
voir avec la région et la qualité d'un
ajustement de la carte des formations
pour pour préparer ces recrutements à
venir et j'espère bien sûr que le jeu il
y aura amplification bien sûr au moment
où on pense qu'il ya un projet si
puisque là pour le coup il faudra
massivement recruté donc là nous
recrutons les gens qui ont besoin d'une
formation longue et nous recruterons un
peu plus tard les gens qui ont besoin
d'une formation un peu plus courte
sachant que l'horizon de production s'il
y avait justement comme un cell c 'est
2019 2018 2020 la formation pétrole
était au moins cinq ans voilà c'est pour
ça qu'on recrute ses dix lits personnes
dans des formations longues pour qu'il
soit prêt dans cinq ans alors on
commence par 10 parce que ce soit les
formations les plus lourdes et ensuite
nous allons moduler tout ça en fonction
de circonstances et causes économiques
donc pour résumer si je me trompe vous
me dites donc c'est deux millions
d'euros de dépenses et sur le territoire
de l'agglo guyane enfin cette fin
septembre ses 150 entreprises mobilisées
c'est à peu près dix neuf employés
directs alors moi je voudrais vous avez
dit l'autre jour que la guyane était
toujours plus proches qu'elle n'était
déjà plus proche que par ramaré que
tribunal est donc à ce niveau plus
compétitif et la sueur vous dites que le
port de dégrad des cannes est une base
secondaire à ce jour alors est ce que
vous nous dire non ce que vous dépensez
ennuis à rapport à ce que vous dépensez
à trinidad et commandante et quand
pensez-vous inversée
cette tendance alors la version 10 parce
que le port de dégrad des cannes sera un
jour plus compétitifs a simplement sur
la distance est peut-être sur d'autres
aspects pour que le port de dégrad des
cannes de vienne le port prioritaires
aussi bien sûr l'objectif parce que
d'abord c'est plus proche donc ça nous
coûte moins cher économiquement nous
avons intérêt à utiliser dégrad des
cannes qui a coté à 150 kilomètres
plutôt qu'un port qui est à 4000 km donc
donc j'ai un objectif parfaitement
alignés en commun entre par contre il
faut il faut pouvoir faire évoluer des
graines pour qu'il puisse accueillir
cette activité
donc j'ai assisté la semaine dernière en
guyane à une présentation d'une
consultant sur les investissements à
faire dans le moyen terme et le long
termes pour que des grades acquiert
cette capacité on parle d'un kiev le
temps dédié
on parle aussi de peut-être utile
changer le mode de fonctionnement du
port pour qu'il soit un peu plus le
problème du pétrole c'est que quelque
part l'activité doit être prioritaire
qui serait financée par keith les
investissements alors ça s'est fait par
ces faits dans le cadre du nouveau grand
port maritime
donc je ne connais pas les les sources
de financement en tout cas les études
sont vraiment engagés avec beaucoup de
retard mais elles sont engagées et
donc je suis très satisfait de voir que
ces études sont engagés parce que c'est
quand même le moyen d de faire d'eux des
grades le port principal d'activité
alors ce que je ne connais pas
aujourd'hui c'est parmi les options qui
sont présentés lesquels seraient retenus
et le temps de la mise en oeuvre tout ce
que ça s'était pas encore disponibles
comme un exemple a répondu sur le saut
sur le rapport deux millions d'euro en
guyane combien trinidad
j'ai pas le chiffre des très jeunes mais
il est plus important puisque vos peu
puisque en terme de jeu penche sur 100
que je pense qu'on doit utiliser
oui je pense que je dis mais je dis ça
rome 28 ivement une dernière question il
ya trois autres millions d'euros qui
sont gérés par la cdc
vous pouvez nous éclairer un peu comment
sont réparties ces fonds governance qui
prend la décision
d'accord ils sont pas gérés par cdc ils
sont accueillis je peux dire la gestion
est assurée par un comité de pilotage
dans lesquelles sont représentés l'état
la région nous puisque nous sommes
financent ordres qu'on a quand même un
d'un intérêt à voir où l'argent est
dépensé et puis j'oublie quelqu'un je
crois qu'il ya quatre parties est un
région nous mêmes
bon désolé pour eux et voilà donc qui
dans le rôle alors il y a trois cent
mille euros qui sont dédiés à la
commission suivi donc chargé de mission
suivi des projets développement
maintenance de sites web
mais ce chargé de projet
sert aussi de chargé de mission pour les
groupes de travail par exemple les
pêcheurs ont besoin d'un chargé de
mission pour développer des projets
pêche ils n'auront un chargé de mission
dédiée à ce groupe que lorsque
l'amplitude du travail nécessitera entre
temps le chargé de mission de la
commission est une ressource qui
l'aurait disponible donc trois cent
mille euros pour la commission et puis
il ya un million d'euros qui ont été
mises à disposition des chercheurs
donc les chercheurs viennent de faire un
programme de d'utilisation de ce fonds
qui est essentiellement un programme de
d'équipements de laboratoire de mutu
d'acquisition de matériels et de me dit
de mutualisation de ces matériels pour
qu'il soit accessible à ifremer cnrs
brgm etc etc sachant que
traditionnellement la recherche a moins
de problèmes pour financer des
programmes que pour financer des
équipements
donc notre rôle est plus d'être un
financeur d'équipements à ce stade
et puis il ya aussi une autre somme
d'argent disponible le jour où il y aura
des projets de développement économique
finalisé que je peux éventuellement
mettre à disposition je pense notamment
aux projets sur la pêche les pêcheurs à
le groupe de travail pêche est très
actif et est déjà identifié un certain
nombre de projets très intéressants pour
la filière projet collectif pour la
filière que nous pourrions
éventuellement aider oui merci mme la
présidente
est ce qu'on peut faire une projection
en termes de quel profil qu'elle quels
enjeux
cela peut représenter en termes d'emploi
aujourd'hui on est dans la prospection
imaginons que nous avions jusqu'à une
concession et que finalement tout cela
se passe comme on peut on peut l'espérer
au mieux
à pato lac sur chacune de ces étapes là
ça représente quoi en terme d'emploi en
termes de recrutements à venir et
surtout qu'elle profite
est ce que l'on a là des des profils je
dirais qui va de d'un salarié de base
dont combien et pour combien de
personnes jusqu'à des ingénieurs etc
enfin quels sont les comment peut-on se
projeter sur un avenir à 15 ans 20 ans
par étapes le travail puisque si c'est
un peu comme les marins lorsqu'ils sont
larges
il faut qu'ils puissent gérer leurs
activités avec autonomy donc on parle
toujours de gens qui sont certifiés pour
pouvoir opérer au large mais ça va de
certification de soudeur à des géologues
ce qui compte c'est là le niveau de
professionnalisation dans l'activité
parce que si vous faites une soudure au
large il faut qu'elle soit bonne du
premier coup là donc
donc ce que l'on recherche c'est
vraiment la qualification pour ça on
recrute dans les sorties des écoles
alors quel que soit le niveau de
qualification et on forme sur le terrain
ou de façon académique chez nous ou chez
les prestataires
de façon à ce que dans cinq ans et
janvier reviennent avec une vraie
qualification et plus être autonome
alors il ya tous les métiers je dirais
si vous prenez une usine chimique c'est
un bon c'est une c'est une espèce du
sinn au large où il ya des gens qui font
l'opération et la maintenance en cycle
continu il ya bien sûr la supervision
l'encadrement au large
il ya les métiers marin je veux dire le
de logistique liés à l'activité il ya
les métiers d'aviateur d'hélicoptères il
ya les métiers de communication et puis
et puis à terre je dirais qu'il ya des
aspects base logistique entreposage
fournitures maintenance réparation dépit
bien sûr tous les services
administratifs des standards pour 1 puis
ensuite un deuxième un deuxième champ
troisième chance etc ajoute ajoute à
chaque fois des gens large alors combien
de personnes au large quand nous avons
des activités un peu similaire au brésil
où il ya à peu près de 150 personnes au
large un d'exploitation rue en
exploitation là aujourd'hui il ya 450
personnes mobilisées sur ce projet mais
c'est ce qu'à 150 personnes sont très
souvent à des experts unique
l'expert en interprétation sismique lui
c'est une denrée rare donc il n'est pas
affecté sur un projet mais il fait les
interprétations les unes à la suite des
autres un peu comme un radiologue de
renom on va faire
ces analyses ils ce sont 450 meinau mais
en guyenne de façon opportuniste
là on parle de 250 direct plus les
métiers indirects plus les induits je
dirais du 700 mille personnes concernées
directement par l'activité mais aimait
bien sûr il ya ensuite à toutes les
revenus que ça génère qui permettent à
la collectivité de développer des
projets d'infrastructure et autres
ma première question a été posée à
l'instant par le collègue c'est
évidemment toujours difficile de se
projeter dans l'avenir avoue n'en est
qu'à la prospection mais si jamais il y
avait exploitation ce n'est pas sûr
c'est vrai que c'est important de voir
réellement ce que ça veut dire en terme
d'emplois locaux pas seulement en termes
de chiffres pas seulement
quantitativement mais effectivement
qualitativement bon mais oui vous venez
de le dire
j'avais deux autres questions la
première j'étais intéressé par ce que
vous avez dit sur les pêcheurs et un
projet vous des projets que vous avez
premièrement et puis j'avais un autre
point qui était que malgré tout je reste
est enfin très très vigilante quant on
voit là à la fois la profondeur à
laquelle vous vous cherchez actuellement
enfin en gros si mm c'était profondeur
quand même très grande et tout ce qu'on
a dit il ya quelques mois quoi en fait
dans des zones sismiques enfin jeu enfin
on a nous avons toujours en tête mais on
attend que vous continuez la prospection
nous avons toujours en tête quand même
les risques et s'il y avait un accident
ce que ça représente
reste aussi sur le plan économique et
social pour le territoire
c'est pas c'est pas simplement se serait
pas simplement une atteinte à
l'environnement on l'a vu dans d'autres
lors d'autres accidents c'est des
conséquences économiques et sociales
terribles quoi donc mais ça c'est plutôt
un point de vue que je développe au
stade où nous en sommes puisque vous en
êtes à la la prospection mais vos
projets vos discussions avec les
pêcheurs si vous pouvez nous sortir une
surprise
j'ai quand même rebondir sur votre
commentaire parce que là je dirais que
nous exploitons nous sommes les premiers
concernés par les aspects sécurité
environnement il est évident que nous
menons nos activités de façon à
atteindre ce qu'on appelle chez nous
l'objectif zéro accident c'est quand
même et ça a été démontrée largement
parce qu'on a pris des décisions
opérationnelles de prudence en valeur
chaque personne qui est sûre cette
activité peut décider d'attendre de dada
d'un ralentir ou d'arrêter travaux s'il
pense qu'il ya un risque aussi minime
soit-il donc parce que je ne je ne
souhaite pas revenir auprès de vous dans
un autre contexte qui sera un contexte
accident que c'est très important pour
nous de ce que nos démarches aucune
démarche pour éviter l'accident en le
terme en termes de prévention dans les
conceptions les choix des matériels
leurs tonnes de procédures comment
est-ce qu'on s'y prend je crois que tous
les tous vos collègues ou les élus qui
sont allés sur le stena sur le bateau
peuvent témoigner d'une organisation
sécurité extrêmement rigoureuse
ceci dit c'est un domaine qui
n'appellent pas de complaisance donc sur
lequel il faut qu'on soit est toujours
extrêmement gyan est pareil sur les
aspects environnementaux qui sont qui
sont présents soucier alors par rapport
aux eaux au pêcheur nous avons identifié
avec eux à ce stade quatre projets 1 qui
concerne la fabrication de glaces donc
une mise en oeuvre d'une chaîne de froid
qui permet donc d'améliorer et l'aspect
sécurité alimentaire mais aussi je
dirais là
la rentabilité de la filière pêche un
poisson un meilleur état mieux
conservées permet de générer plus de
revenus
un aspect avitaillement donc des
pêcheurs qui peuvent profiter des prix
de gros de shell entre guillemets un
projet de motorisation hybride faut
savoir que les artisans pêcheurs en
guyane navigue d'un d eau très boueuse
vrai qu'ils sont les autres charges et
d'alluvions de caractéristiques de ces
fleuves et rivières et que donc il ya
énormément de problèmes de maintenance
des moteurs traditionnels donc il ya
toute une étude consistant à faire des
conceptions de moteurs plus adaptées au
milieu et j'en oubliais ce voilà le
genre alors les projets pour qu'il soit
intéressant pour nous en tant que
support du comptoir c'est qu'ils soient
collectifs qui doivent bénéficier à la
filière mais les besoins sont importants
à vie et l'autre projet c'est le projet
2.0 d'étude d'analysé de la ressource
halieutique sur une longue durée mais
dans le contexte d'un d'une exploitation
au large je parlais tout à tout à
l'heure de la nécessité de construire
une connaissance scientifique du milieu
et les pêcheurs soient pas intéressés
par cette dimension ressources pour la
pêche associés à l'activité
alors ces projets sont en cours de
définition
voilà et j'espère qu'on pourra bientôt
en initier sapin est-ce que chers
collègues en à l'épuiser les
interrogations sur le deuxième thème sur
ses retombées économiques
oui donc nous pouvons aborder si vous
voulez bien le codm d'un cran
d'accord en prêt alors je pensais que
total aurait l'occasion de parler je
veux dire en général les différents
systèmes donc j'avais pas prévu d'en
parler moi même ce que je peux dire en
préalable c'est que les forages en mer
comporte un certain nombre de
spécificités par rapport par rapport à
je dirais à des forages à terre
nous ferons dans des zones économiques
non pas sur le territoire national et je
dirais que les moyens les expertises et
les coûts de mise en oeuvre sont sont
différents je dirais d'un puits dans un
champ c'est neymar je parle de
l'amplitude 1 ce sont les mêmes
préoccupations sécurité environnement
mais les moyens mobilisés sont très
différents en plus lorsque vous ferez en
sur le territoire national enfin en
france dans l'hexagone
vous savez sur quelques minutes vous
êtes lorsque vous êtes à 200 km des
côtes
la notion de commune édifices les plus
difficiles à appréhender
alors qu'aujourd'hui là je dirais le
code minier est très orienté commune et
c'est donc
donc voilà il ya donc il ya quand même
des spécificités et puis je rappelle que
pour mobiliser les moyens les moyens à
mobiliser sont rares est important qu'il
faut un système qui permettent à
l'investisseur de mobiliser ses moyens
sans risque je note que l'évolution va à
plus d'information du public ce qui est
légitime mais ce qu'il faut pour l'off
shore d'abord savoir qu'elle les publics
que l'on informe je me réfère à l'aspect
communal des choses et puis deuxièmement
il faut que l'information soit très
borné dans le temps par opposition à des
enquêtes d'utilité publique
traditionnelle ou finalement
on sait quand elle commence on sait pas
forcément quand elles se terminent ce
modèle là pour l'offshore est un est une
catastrophe puisque voyez bien que je
peux pas mobilisé 450 personnes qui
attendent la fin d'une d'un processus
d'information du public parce qu'il
irait au delà des des échéanciers
préprogrammés donc il faut qu'ils la
formation depuis qu'il ya vraiment un
besoin de bornes et de façon à ce qu'on
puisse prendre une décision de
mobilisation accès à tout pour moi ça
c'est un des très grands aspects
spécifiques à leurs champs ensuite
l'ampleur des investissements notamment
lorsque vous subissez des échecs dans
l'exploration et et le coût de
développement des projets est colossal
le développement commercial d'un champ
au large de la guyane
c'est supérieur à 10 milliards de
dollars ses supérieurs un coût d'une
centrale nucléaire où ces mêmes têtes au
coût de 2 on parle de le projet lourd
or investir ce genre de somme de mon
temps nécessite une démence clarté sur
les paramètres de l'adhésion
d'investissement donc il faut qu'il y
ait une grande instabilité ou
prédictibilité fiscale et puis et puis
il faut aussi que qui est un juste
retour sur cet investissement nous
devons travailler développer des projets
onéreux nous avons des exigences de
sécurité extrêmes il faut que
l'investisseur soient rémunérés de façon
équitable pour ses efforts et puis il
lui faut aussi pouvoir développer dans
le développement de son portefeuille de
chant donc il faut toujours garder en
tête qu'il faut que la fiscalité soit
équitable que donne envie d'investir
et puis évidemment il faut que la
collectivité y trouve son compte ça
c'est évident mais mais pour moi ces
paramètres
compte tenu de l'ampleur des
investissements prennent d'autant plus
de poids
et puis vous voyez que si je fais un
programme de dix forages dans un champ
dans l'hexagone il est assez facile de
moduler son programme je forge fort
j'arrête je reprends plus tard les
conséquences sont complètement
différentes de 2,2 et 2,2 g 450
personnes mobilisées la rupture de
charge donc pour moi c'est l'inquiétude
et les ruptures de charge dans le
programme de travail
après il y a des ya l'aspect zone
économique
aujourd'hui nous nous travaillons toute
clarté nous savons qu'elle nous en plus
le droit du pavillon s'applique sur les
activités sur les navires
la réglementation douanière est connu
mais il ya énormément de questions et de
challenge autour de ça donc il faut je
pense aussi clarifier ses aspects pour
l'avenir encore une fois lorsque
l'amplitude des investissements des
dépenses est elle qui a vraiment besoin
de sécurité sur le sujet vous aviez déjà
posé le problème sur la stabilité
réglementaire et fiscal vous êtes en
dialogue avec les pouvoirs publics sur
cet aspect précis pas trop parce que
d'abord les videmment c'est là on est
vraiment dans la prérogative de l'état
de définir mais mais je pense pas que ce
soit aujourd'hui au coeur des
préoccupations
on est plus sur des préoccupations de
l'information du public de mise en
conformité du code minier de quad
environnementale
ce sont les les propos exprimés relève
plus de ce domaine que du domaine de la
stabilité fiscale et réglementaire
à ce stade c'est pourquoi j'attire votre
attention plus particulièrement sur ce
point
mes chers collègues
est-ce que vous avez encore des
questions oui c'est simplement vous avez
dit en introduction que il n'y est pas
il ya des cadres fiscal
simplement on peut rappeler quand même
que il ya la loi de finances de 2011
donc il ya une répartition 50 50 et des
collectivités sur une assiette de 12%
alors si on retient cet aspect fiscal et
sur la pratique un peu qui existe en
france parce que tu as fait une analyse
comparative sur les formes de juridique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer
selon vous que serait le meilleur
dispositif sous forme de concessions
sous forme de partage des bénéfices dans
à nous éclairer rapport à vos
pratiques ailleurs est aussi un
éclairage sur ce comité de suivi qui
actuellement mis actuellement place en
guyane une question comment percevez
vous la position du pouvoir public
à l'intérieur de ce comité de suivi et
par rapport à ce projet industriel est
ce que vous êtes bien accompagné est-ce
que donc vous avez un certain temps de
réponse donc en fait tu veux votre
analyse qui sont vertes sur l'évolution
dont de ce comité de suivi et devrait
être s'orienter vers une gouvernance
décentralisée comme c'est un peu le ko
signe aux etats-unis qu'au royaume uni à
partir de cette expérience en guyane ce
qu'il y aura quelque chose à améliorer
alors vous demande pas de légiférer nous
allons le faire mais peut-être en tant
que pratiquant dans d'autres pays quel
serait d'après vous le meilleur
dispositif est d'accord
alors premièrement nous nous accommodons
fort bien d'un système de concessions
il a en général beaucoup davantage d'un
autre point de vue nous qui connaissons
les systèmes divers et variés c'est donc
c'est un très bon système
donc le principe aujourd'hui qui est
d'avoir des permis exclusifs de
recherche puis sinon découvre donne un
droit à a demandé une concession kita
qui est instruite est un bon système
lorsqu'on parle de 12% beaucoup de gens
trouvent ça faible parce que on entend
des taux de prélèvement de 85% de 60% et
donc d'où sa part est faible mais je
rappelle qu'en france on parle de 12% du
chiffre d'affaires ont pas alors que
ceux qui parlent de 60 81% par 64 ans 60
du bénéfice ce qui est complètement
différent donc beaucoup de gens pensent
qu'il faudrait taxer 70% du chiffre
d'affaires
et là je vous garantis qu'il n'y a aucun
investisseur c'est d'abord ça naze et si
je prélève 70% type d'affaires il n'y a
aucune chance de financer un
investissement de 10 milliards donc
donc je pense que le système actuel est
en fait pas mal il ya un cap à 12% tout
à définir en fonction justement de ces
composantes essentielles qui sont
l'investissement le coût de
développement et ses terres extrêmes
après j'ai noté bien sûr que que le
législateur avait prévu une des
retombées locales et la titreront
personnel pour le coup parce que nous
savons il ya un prélèvement le paye mais
maintenant dans cydia je trouve bien
qu'ils aient des retombées locales parce
que mon expérience dans d'autres pays
c'est que lorsqu'il n'y a pas un lien
entre l'activité et les revenus locaux
il y à frustration
ce qu'on pense toujours que c'est
l'autre qui profitent de la situation
donc j'ai noté ça par exemple par
rapport à la taxe professionnelle où
nous avions des mères qui était qui
soutenait au projet parce qu'il voyait
un lien direct entre soutenir un projet
et un revenu aujourd'hui ce lien a été
atténuée et donc si je prends l'analogie
pour nos activités c'est un peu pareil
il faut quelque part que qu'il ya un
lien alors le lien est à définir mais
moi je trouve que c'est bien qu'ils
aient ce lien très personnelle là pour
le coup toujours par rapport à la
présentation de nos travaux avec
beaucoup la direction bon ne sont pas
des experts mais ce qui ressort c'est
que pour vous mais pour le public on se
perd dans le co2 minier notamment par
rapport à cette activité d'hydrocarbures
parce que vous serez favorable à ce
qu'il y ait une loi ou un chapitre
didier dans la réforme du code minier à
cette exploitation donc d'hydrocarbures
ou bien au chaud ou bien ça vous
convient vous arrivez à vous retrouver
dans ce qu de mini actuelle ou bien un
peu comme le brésil par exemple où
est-ce qu'ils ont une voie spécifique de
2010 ou bien d'autres pays qui ont des
chapitres dédiés à cette activité ou
bien ça vous convient tels que les
articles sont noyés sujet
je participe à un groupe informel sur la
réforme du code minier
on parle de plus en plus de la prise en
considération sa planque d'autres
externalités comme la pré exploitation
par exemple qu'est ce que vous en pensez
encore une fois j'ai l'impression que
les évolutions récentes du communier en
plus servi à insérer nos projets que l'
inverse si je dirais que c'est un peu le
projet guyane qui a créé un peu un peu
d'énergie sur une refonte du code minier
enfin récemment je suis passé ancien
dans le domaine pour savoir ce qui se
passait avant maintenant je me méfie un
peu des lois qui cherche à tout résoudre
le nickel c'est pas la même chose que le
pétrole offshore alors je ne sais pas si
le législateur a les moyens de faire
quelque chose de simple stable et qui
marche pour tous mais intuitivement il
me semble que il me semble que le call
off shore a quand même des spécificités
j'ai un autre exemple on sort de
l'exploitation offshore effectivement
mais par exemple ce qui nous est dit on
a un certain de l'interpellation qui
nous arrive de deux syndicalistes
notamment du site petroplus il
semblerait que le sol est très pollué et
que vous ne souvenez vous ne
voulait pas participer aux frais de
dépollution qui serait aux frais de
l'état et qui sauvegarde
je vous remercie infiniment pour cette
question parce que vous m'offrez les
manifs et réduit pour clarifier
certaines nations j'ai pas eu le temps
de vérifier puisque vous êtes là
monsieur le président on sort peut-être
du g20 mais peut-être pas tant que ça il
ya des sommes énormes qui nous sont
données et c'est l'état qui devrait
payer puisque faillite etc
permettez-moi déjà de clarisse de
clarifier tout ça d'abord je vous
rappelle que nous avons vendu ce site il
y à presque 50 et que nous avons
parfaitement respecté la loi donc et
nous avons une dette nul
shell n'a pas de dettes juridique non
après il faut voir que je prends
l'exemple de la raffinerie de reichstett
qui a fermé récemment ce que tout le
monde a tendance à oublier c'est que les
terrains ont une valeur tout le monde
pense coûts de remise en état des
terrains mais personne ne pense à valeur
des terrains au moins une étape
si vous prenez l'exemple de la ravine
reste est qu un exemple concret est en
cours
aucun contribuable va payer un centime
pour la remise en état des sols
pourquoi parce qu'une personne a racheté
le terrain pour un euro et va leur
vendre au prix de la dépollution
la valeur de la réserve foncière est
supérieur au coût de la dépollution tech
il n'y a aucune dette
ce serait ignorer la valeur des terrains
donc shell n'a aucune dette
le contribuable n'a aucune dette à
honorer il ya simplement si si hélas il
n'y a pas de projet de reprise de ce
site et j'espère qu'un haut rhin et s'il
n'y en a pas ça veut dire que quelqu'un
se portera acquéreur de ce site
financera la dépollution sur ses fonds
et revendra le terrain à un prix
supérieur ou égal au coût de la
dépollution
il ya il n'y a pas de dette et où et
c'est d'ailleurs je pense donc
donc je ne vois pas en quoi quelqu'un
peut me dire que je laisse une ardoise à
quiconque
d'abord il n'ya pas d'art d'oise et en
plus ce n'est pas moi qui la laisse je
rappelle que je respecte la loi et que
la loi pour un site classé stipule que
c'est le dernier le dernier exploitant
qui responsable
vous n'aimez peut-être pas la loi mais
vous pouvez pas m'accuser de ne pas la
respecter pas de la respecter a
interpellé en ces termes monsieur le
président j'ai bien compris mais alors
justement puisque nous interrogeons sur
une évolution éventuelle de la loi c'est
à ce propos ça ce propos là que je
posais la question est maintenant loin
de l'usure bon voilà vous avez j'ai bien
compris que il ya aujourd'hui un autre
exploitant que vous avez vendu et que
c'est plus vous mais le fait est que on
se voit là on a une question puisqu'on
se pose la question de faire évoluer la
loi on a une question là qui va payer
dans le cas précis pour la dépollution
de ce sol
c'est l'état sachant que l'actuelle
petroplus est en faillite quoi et qu'on
est on n'y a pas de repreneur
je posais cette question vous avez
l'exemple l'utilisateur pour les
législateurs ouais je ne vous ai pas dit
que vous ne respectez pas la levée sont
riches
non mais regardez reichstett le
liquidateur a vendu le terrain à une
société dont le métier c'est de
revitaliser des friches industrielles et
cet opérateur le fait parce qu'il
retrouve son compte donc il a trouvé
dans la valeur immobilière de ces
terrains suffisamment de motivation pour
financer la dépollution
voilà donc il faut pas oublier la valeur
du terrain
c'est comme si j'ai l'impression qu'on
parle d'une décharge et dont on ignorait
qu'un coût assumé mais aucune valeur en
retirer si vous pensez à ce site à petit
couronne c'est un site absolument majeur
en termes de localisation portes de
rouen portes de paris proximité de la
scène des autoroutes chemins de fer il a
tous les atouts pour en faire un
développement multimodal est là et cette
valeur est très significative donc il
faut bon il ya le discours qui
consistent à un de discours revendicatif
qui chercha à pointer le dos de
quelqu'un mais la réalité c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de dette et que je ne vois pas
en quoi le contribuable devrait être
amené à payer quoi que ce soit je
connais des gens qui sont prêts à
apporter des projets ces projets des
sceaux ne sont pas développés puisqu'il
faut d'abord attendre la conclusion de
alors après vous pourriez changer la loi
pour dire que le sur un principe
pollueur payeur
mais si cette loi avait existé 50 pour
nous serait pas été un problème
puisqu'on aurait peut-être conserver une
forme de dette là pour le coup mais nous
aurions ajuster notre prix de vente en
conséquence
et peut-être que nous nous porterions
acquéreurs du terrain pour un euro pour
réaliser au pea sont juifs ou nounous
sous-traitent orient à quelqu'un de
faire tout ça ne change rien ça parce
que ça vous rend la vie beaucoup
difficile parce que vous allez devoir
remonter sur 50 ans pour savoir qui a
été présent 150 ans alors que le fait
d'avoir un dernier exploitant c'est au
moins simple de ce point de vue alors
quand il a fait faillite il ya la
logique de la liquidation qui
interfèrent mai mais c'est finalement un
but un système plutôt bon nous allons
mettre un terme à cet entretien vous
remercions beaucoup monsieur le
président vous et vos collaborateurs
je pense que ce rapport d'étape est tout
à fait utile pour notre délégation
il y aura d'autres étapes nous vous
solliciteront sans doute dans le courant
de l'année 2013 pour voir comment s'est
traduit concrètement ce que vous nous
avez dit aujourd'hui encore une fois
merci beaucoup
voilà pour l'audition de patrick roméo
le président directeur général de shell
france qui défend un projet de forage
pétrolier en guyane
vous pourrez évidemment la revoir à tout
instant sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne matinée à tous sur notre
chaîne